[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number
50 what it's number 50. it is november
it's number 50. i am brett weinstein i
am sitting with the lovely doctor
heather heing
and we have another another
instantiation of the dark horse podcast
in store for you we do indeed with cats
lurking in the background yep
and um just want to mention that you
released yesterday your conversation
with greg lukianov i believe that was
yesterday
um also an excellent conversation yes
people should check that out it's a
great conversation greg and i had a
really good time
for reasons that are not worth going
into it got released late at night which
i think caused a hiccup in the algorithm
so people may
not be uh seeing that it's out but
anyway uh take a look on the dark horse
channel you will find it
yeah so this week uh i would like
to spend a lot of time talking uh
responding in effect to
this excellent new book by rod drear
live not by lies
prompted by my reading and excerpt from
the sultan socially hmm essay by the
same name
last week which um at the time i did not
know that
drear had recently released this book um
named for the social needs an essay and
someone in our super chat questions last
week
pointed me to it i bought the book i've
read it
and it's excellent it deserves a
full-throated defense and discussion
and i think we're going to frame much of
what we're going to do today
around around that that said you have
not read it i have i have
shared with you some of it and um what
i'd like to do doesn't require that
you've read it so long as you
trust that i am not misrepresenting um
what what he's doing in the book
i have been in contact with the author
and i have uh
paid attention to some of his interview
material so i am
uh well aware of his direction if not
the precise details
yeah so before that though i'd like to
start with
um a brief reading a brief excerpt from
another excellent piece of writing that
that actually
came out this week and that we both read
this week which is barry weiss's
new essay in tablet magazine stop being
shocked
in which she argues much as dreer does
in his book
albeit from a different perspective that
american liberalism is at risk
so zack if you would just share my my
site here for a moment
um this is this is the piece came out a
couple of days ago
and i'm just gonna read a bit starting
here to understand the enormity of the
change we are now living through
take a moment to understand america as
the overwhelming majority of its jews
believed it was
and perhaps as we always assumed it
would be it was liberal
not liberal in the narrow partisan sense
but liberal in the most capacious and
distinctly american sense of that word
the belief that everyone is equal
because everyone is created in the image
of god
the belief in the sacredness of the
individual over the group or the tribe
the belief that the rule of law and
equality under that law is the
foundation of a free society
the belief that due process and the
presumption of innocence are good and
that mob violence is bad
the belief that pluralism is a source of
our strength that tolerance is a reason
for pride
and that liberty of thought faith and
speech are the bedrocks of democracy
the liberal worldview was one that
recognized that there were things indeed
the most important things in life that
were located outside of the realm of
politics
friendships art music family love
this was a world in which antony and
scalia and ruth bader ginsburg could be
close friends
because as scalia once said some things
are more important than votes
crucially this liberalism relied on the
view that the enlightenment tools of
reason and the scientific method might
have been designed by dead white guys
but they belonged to everyone
and they were the best tools for human
progress that have ever been devised
racism was evil because it contradicted
the foundations of this world view
since it judged people not based on the
content of their character but on the
color of their skin
and while america's founders were guilty
of undeniable hypocrisy their own moral
failings did not invalidate their
transformational project
the founding documents were not evil to
the core but magnificent
as martin luther king jr put it because
they were quote
a promissory note to which every
american was to fall air
in other words the founders themselves
planted the seeds of slavery's
destruction
and our second founding fathers
abolitionists like frederick douglass
made it so america would never be
perfect but we could always strive
toward building a more perfect union
i didn't even know that this worldview
had a name because it was baked into
everything i came into contact with
barry weiss writes my parents worldviews
the schools they sent me to the
synagogues we attended the magazines and
newspapers we read and so on
i was among many millions of americans
costed by these ideals since world war
ii
american intellectual and cultural life
has been produced and protected by a set
of institutions
universities newspapers magazines record
companies professional associations
labor unions
cultural venues publishing houses
hollywood studios think tanks
historical museums art museums that
align broadly with those principles
as such they had incredible power power
that demanded our respect because they
held up the liberal order
no longer american liberalism is under
siege
there is a new ideology vying to replace
it
may i have my screen back zach thank you
um
so earlier in the essay just one more
very brief quote from barry she says
barry wise the confusion and there seems
to be a good deal of it these days is
among american jews
who think that by submitting to
ever-changing loyalty tests they can
somehow maintain the old status quo and
their place inside of it
i share that first not merely because it
is
as we have come to expect from barry
both
insightful and incisive in terms of its
ideas but also beautiful
and careful writing but also because
you might imagine if you had fallen prey
to the modern ideology
that someone like barry who was raised
who was raised not particularly
secularly right that she is she is
jewish and she is proud of her
judaism and rod drear who
is unapologetically christian and indeed
the subtitle of his book
lived not by lies is a manual for
christian dissidents
that barry and rod might not have much
in common
but of course they do and we do uh and
uh drear has uh referred to uh
not just the two of us brett um but also
barry weiss and james lindsay
as the secular liberals uh with whom he
finds himself in
allyship and this is a kind of allyship
that is
um that is honorable and real and
important
particularly right now so
uh i want to place this in a little bit
of context maybe a couple different
kinds of context first of all i should
say the essay
is excellent and well worth a complete
read
it is very much from a jewish
perspective
and i want to point out why this is
so resonant so barry's thesis
in her most recent book is effectively
that when the center doesn't hold it
collapses on jews that this is the
explanation for
many of the atrocities that history has
seen and
um so in effect she is raising the alarm
that the center is collapsing and we can
talk and we have talked over the last
50 episodes and elsewhere about
why the center is collapsing in effect
it is being punished out of existence by
fringes on both sides but nonetheless
the recognition that there is
um a kind of paralysis which i must say
i am seeing also in
many of the sort of private discussions
that we are party to these days where
there's so much to be seen
in the breaking apart of this agreement
in the center and i don't mean centrism
but this agreement about the basic
principles
that we should collectively defend
that there is a temptation to simply
catalogue and marvel and gawk at
all of the various examples of things
going wrong
rather than to well maybe i shouldn't
say that people
do extrapolate to what this means about
where we are headed collectively
but there is no agreement about what
the details of that are like liable to
look like and
what we ought to do about it so we see
people fleeing cities for example
but there's no consensus about how much
of this remains abstract how much this
could turn into uh you know an atrocity
on our own shores and this is part of
why
i find you know that we are going to
talk about
um three of the things that i pulled
from
drier's book um that we have talked
about separately but that he really puts
um front and center that are ways
um that those of us who are maybe
dissident christians
or uh jews watching the center collapse
or secular liberals or you know some
combination
of of those or or outside of any of
those groups and yet watching this
this what dreer calls a soft
totalitarianism or
therapeutic totalitarianism that we need
to return
to some principles that we will talk
about here of
the value of family the value of privacy
and the value of community and how is it
that we can actually
uh recover and um and reinvigorate our
own
our own selves above and beyond the
level of the individual
to return ourselves to family privacy
and
uh community right and so um
the orientation to those things which
strike people in some ways as
conservative isn't
is also an indicator of the reason for
the alliance which i think once you spot
it is all
you know it's very intuitive right
between for example
christians and jews now i hope
we will not forget at some point to take
the visible alliance that is emerging
here if it's even an alliance if that's
even the right
terminology for it and place it in an
evolutionary context because i do think
there's something important to be said
about whether or not uh you know
obviously jews and christians
are distinct on the other hand judeo
christianity
is something and so putting that in
evolutionary context probably makes a
lot of sense
just just at its most at the simplest
level
christianity emerges from judaism right
and so
um you know if you apply the tools of
phylogenetic systematics
in a place where admittedly not all of
the assumptions are perfectly
met but they're met well enough that we
can justify it at least at the level of
a very strong analogy it would be
like a large clade of creatures emerging
from a comparatively small clade of
creatures which of course is something
that happened
many times in history so christianity is
in some sense a form of judaism
and protestantism is a form of
christianity and so forth
um but then there is also this other
fact which is
that many of the belief structures
that are innovated in christianity have
moved culturally into judaism and so in
some sense christians are
phylogenetically
jewish and jews are memetically
christians
which is you know once once you spot the
implications of that
the whole thing makes a lot more sense
yeah and so the secular liberalism
uh so named by dreher which we will
return to
uh is um in some ways formalized it's
formalized across many
uh many faiths um but um
we in the west i think are most familiar
with it in christianity
and it has become all of our birthrights
right it is it is
um it is as as barry weiss writes in the
essay from which i read and
as dreer writes uh uh in this book
uh something that uh that we are all
we are all born to and most of us i
think have
expected would continue um and so you
know drear is sounding the alarm saying
people who actually lived under
totalitarian regimes
which is you know to say in eastern
europe mostly not very long ago
are seeing what is happening in the west
right now
and saying no this doesn't look exactly
like history
but yes there are too many things that
are familiar
such that anyone who is not concerned
right now is
blind either willfully or not so i i
think it does warrant saying as well
since we're talking about
the the sort of phylogenetic
relationship between christianity and
judaism
and the cultural effectively the
cultural borrowing
of some of the so-called liberal ideals
from
from the teachings of jesus by um the
vast majority of people who call
themselves secular liberals which
includes
um i think a you know a majority of jews
at least in america
um that you and i to some degree come
from these two different traditions as
well
right that you well maybe you you can
speak in
you know a couple of sentences about the
home that you were raised in but i was
raised
mostly without religion um but my father
was a
lapsed catholic who um
not as it turns out on his deathbed but
at one point when we thought he might
um not come out of open-heart surgery
did ask actually to see
a priest and and talk to him which um
which as far as we know he hadn't done
for
you know decades and so he a man of
science a man of reason a man who prized
enlightenment values
was in some ways a man of faith as well
and although
he took me into a church i believe once
and only once to see the midnight mass
one christmas eve
um and so you know never never took
to me the faith that he was raised with
on a you know on a
on a farm in northeastern iowa in the in
the 40s and 50s
it was part of part of how he was um how
he informed his own view and
and my mother also emerges from a
christian tradition although had
had no um was not raised with any faith
herself and and
they did not raise me with any and so
for
my part i was raised in a home that was
decidedly
secular both my parents are jewish but
um it was you know there was ceremonial
observance but
uh nothing based on uh
faith i would say and that went back
you know a couple generations on my
mom's side um
but my best friend growing up actually
was in a jewish home that was
observant and kept kosher and i think
believing
and so anyway i got exposure to it that
way
among others um so anyway i think
actually
before you go on um i don't there's so
many places
that we could go today and there's a lot
that i do want to get to and we may just
be we may just end up going longer than
than we normally do
but one of the things i started doing in
um
thinking about this book and barry's
essay and really everything that's going
on in the world for
depending on how you count you know
decades now um
was how is it that people end up uh
resisting the the ideology the
what many of us are seeing as a creeping
totalitarianism and
i was thinking for instance of myself
you know happened
i don't know i don't remember how i
ended up for instance in a
class on sultanates in encumbra my first
quarter in college as a literature major
but
how lovely for me that i did and um and
you know then that i pursued the
writings of jorge louis borges
um who you know very different kind of
guy but you know also brought just
ideas from a completely different world
that was informed by
different life experiences than anyone i
had ever met
similarly you know you you can talk
about
um you know your best friend growing up
having been uh
being being in quite a religious um
family several
many of my friends growing up were
jewish as as you know and
my mother's dearest friend and for a
period business partner was jewish as
well and
um and the times that we had at her
house
and the ability for me to learn from her
her mother
who had come over from poland actually
um who had who had fled
to learn how to make latkes for instance
you know i was sort of immersed in the
stew
of secular judaism in a way
um but then also um surrounded by a
tremendous number of
gay men who were the artistic friends of
my mother and her dearest friend
during the emerging aids crisis as they
didn't know what was happening and they
were watching their friends die and
you know so how what how do all of those
different experiences
inform a person such that they grow up
and as an ideology shows
and says follow me follow me or you're a
bad person
what is it what what all is it in a
person's experiences that allow them to
say
i'm not a bad person and actually
following you
might send me down a path that could
turn me into one
so i want to connect a couple things up
here yeah one
there's something interesting in the
fact that even now i couldn't tell you
um whether or not the family that i had
so much contact with growing up
was had any faith in the supernatural
i assumed there was some but there is
something to be said
for on the jewish side of the equation
it is very
frequent for jews to have a personal
and i think complex relationship with
the idea
of faith that can go up through
having no faith in the supernatural
whatsoever and still being
observant and so um over
time i've come to understand you know if
we take barry's perspective for example
that the center has to hold in order for
jews to have a place in most societies
um that there is a
an anti-fragility to jews because
frankly they've faced so many of these
different catastrophes
and i would say as an evolutionary
biologist it's a little bit surprising
that um we haven't gone extinct right
and that it has to do with certain kinds
of
um wisdom about how to endure these
things often not very well but simply to
persist through an era in which the
center has not held and so
one of the things you know on the
christian side it's very frequent that
as people lose their faith
they also lose their tradition and
so one of the things that i think may be
to be learned from the jewish side is
that there's a reason not to do that
even at the point that something
challenges
faith that there is you know it's
chesterton's fence
all over the place there are all of
these protective traditions that may not
be straightforward in the way that they
protect in other words you know
metaphorical truths may be
offering some kind of immunity and we
speak actually we invoke
in in the book that we are writing
chesterton's gods
you know abandon them at your peril how
do you know what all they are doing for
you and you know we say this is people
without faith
yep um so um
i think we are seeing and uh drear
you know is pointing to it and barry
is in her own way pointing to it as well
that it is not at all surprising that
you know if it's on the christian side
maybe it's almost exclusively people who
have retained the kind of faith because
they've also retained the traditions
that has
put a break on um runaway liberalism and
that doesn't mean
ambitious liberalism i think ambition
ambitious liberalism
created the west but runaway liberalism
is very dangerous and we've seen
it drive societies into the ground
before so there's a question about
whether that's where we're headed
but to see people come from religious
traditions of different kinds
and begin to sound the alarm from
different places and create
alliances is um it's at least hopeful
yeah no i i think it is exactly that and
that's
that hope is part of why i wanted to
start with
with barry weiss's essay before moving
into uh
uh a more expensive extensive discussion
of
drears book um so i want to read just
just a page really from the very
beginning um and
i am going to almost certainly butcher
every name
uh in here from eastern europe because i
don't know um
i don't know how to pronounce with the
accents and i couldn't seem to find it
almost anywhere on
the website i think you should just
declare a kind of narrow post-modernism
surrounding pronunciation
that will protect you yeah i used to do
this with regard to latin names of
organisms when students would say how is
it pronounced and you know there are
rules and i know some of them and i
would
tell them and then i would say really if
you if you don't know and you're giving
a presentation you say it with some
authority
and uh and you just be consistent what
you don't want to do is keep on
moving back and forth between
pronunciations that is a terrible rule
but okay
i accept it um so
kolakovic i don't i don't know if that's
the the name
uh the pronunciation chapter one of
dreher's book
lived not by lives is called kolakovic
the prophet
sometimes drier writes a stranger who
sees deeper and farther than the crowd
appears to warn of trouble coming
these stories often end with people
disbelieving the prophet and suffering
for their blindness
here though is a tale about a people who
heard the prophet's warnings did as he
advised and were ready when the crisis
struck
in 1943 a jesuit priest and anti-fascist
activist
named tomoslav fled his native croatia
one step ahead of the gestapo and
settled in czechoslovakia
to conceal himself from the nazis he
assumed his slovak mother's name
kolakovic and took up a teaching
position in bratislava the capital of
the slovak region which had become an
independent vassal state of hitler
the priest 37 years old and with a thick
shock of prematurely white hair had
spent some of his
had spent some of his priestly training
studying the soviet union
he believed the defeat of nazi
totalitarianism would occasion a great
conflict between soviet totalitarianism
and the liberal oops and the liberal
sorry he believed the defeat of nazi
totalitarianism would occasion a great
conflict between soviet totalitarianism
and the liberal democratic west
though father kolakovic worried about
the threats to christian life and
witnessed from the rich materialistic
west
he was far more concerned about the
dangers of communism which he correctly
saw as an imperialistic ideology
by the time by the time father kolokovic
reached baraslava it was clear that the
red army would defeat the germans in the
east
in fact in 1944 the czech government in
exile which also represented slovaks who
refused to accept the nominally
independent slovak state
made a formal agreement with stalin
guaranteeing that after driving the
nazis out the soviets would give the
reunited nation its freedom
because he knew how the soviets thought
father kolokovic knew this was a lie
he warned slovak catholics that when the
war ended czechoslovakia would fall to
the rule of a soviet puppet government
he dedicated himself to preparing them
for persecution
drier then tells the story of how he um
father kolakovic truly did create a
number of
small communities um who
created among other things sam is that
you know dissident literature published
on tiny presses that were hidden from
the authorities
and um and thus kept not just faith
alive but truth and an understanding of
underlining lying realities and
love and beauty as well and um
one reason i wanted to share just that
just that little bit from the book
um is to point out that um this is a man
klockovic who was an anti-fascist in the
i don't know if that was the original
meaning of the term if that was when the
idea was was first formulated i think it
was but i'm not totally sure
um but contrast that with the people who
are now calling themselves anti-fascists
it's not the same
it's not the same descent it's not the
same
resistance and we're going to get to
um why i think um why we think
some of the confusion exists but
you know please we've heard from some
people who
really actually i think are legitimately
confused because
the resistance at the moment has named
itself antifa
and it's not the only part of the
resistance that is
in the streets and rioting and such
but being able to name yourself
something that aligns with an
historically
uh important and uplifting and
truth-seeking group
does not make you that thing and yet
people are being fooled
yeah i think you know it occurs to me in
this moment i hope this works
that the tell with respect to antifa
is that it is anarchist right there's
nothing
about anti-fascism in the literal sense
that should travel with anarchism right
in fact i would argue this is in in
effect a non-sequitur
right and that you know that
anarchism has put on the cloak of
anti-fascism
in order that it can engage in
destructive behavior
and get away with it is not surprising
right right
you you need to have some sort of a
defense and in fact uh anarchism
was a knit fringe
idea that always lurked at some you know
tiny insignificant level in the pacific
northwest and then it suddenly
uh took up anti-racism and anti-fascism
as those things
uh became fashionable um okay
it's obvious what the ploy is and we
have an obligation not to listen to it
right yes we do yes
is that yeah that's effectively yeah
yeah we we we absolutely do and i think
you know that wraps into
um drier's framing of i've already
mentioned a soft totalitarianism
or also a therapeutic totalitarianism in
which
uh in his language hatred of dissenters
from this utopian ideology
comes in the guise of helping and
healing how could you resist us we're
just trying to help
or how could you resist us what we are
doing is
fighting a history of oppression and
therefore if you resist
us you approve of the oppression and you
yourself are an oppression
an oppressor um it's a not even very
clever sophisticated sleight of hand
sort of linguistic
um trick and yet uh yet many are fooled
in part because
um being called racist or sexist or any
of the things that people are now being
called with
with wild abandon is
feels like such a terrible fate
that people who have not yet unjustly
been called those things
cannot imagine how they could possibly
survive being on the other side of it
and yet um and yet you do and if it if
you simply know
yourself and have good people around you
who know you who also know yourself well
enough to know that those slurs are not
true
you not only survive it but it reveals a
kind of anti-fragility
um that you have upon being called these
things i believe
yeah it's you know i think the pattern
is
is pretty clear which is you are raised
to the extent
if we grant liberalism the full breadth
of the honorable
version you are raised to understand the
bigotry
that you have overcome right sexism is
bad
racism is bad fascism is bad
but the problem is that these terms are
inherently
perfectly elastic that is to say they
can be stretched
right down to the border of what can be
measured you can be
zero and in fact we see this in candy's
absurd definition
of anti-racism is that it rules out that
there's any gap
you know where you can just simply be
non-racist you're either racist
or you're fully active on this other
side so you know it has been stretched
to the point that um the mind that
understands i i do not want to be a
racist
is then sort of susceptible to this
command oh
here's how you avoid being a racist you
become an anti-racist what's an
anti-racist well here's a list of things
you would have to do
right yes so yes that elastas that
elastic nature of the definitions
you know is of course a kafka trap as as
we've mentioned i do want to ask you
though
this term soft totalitarianism
i have a feeling that we are about to at
a
societal level end up in
a discussion over whether or not this
totalitarianism that we are seeing
is soft whether it is just early
whether we are headed down some
different road than we've seen clearly
some of the details are different
well i think part of part of the
argument
is it is not um state driven
and so um it comes in
looking quite different and it comes in
looking like
the exhortations of your colleagues at
work
or your children's teachers
or just neighbors and of course we know
from
history that some of the most effective
totalitarian regimes have used the young
and have used uh the ability to turn
people against their own family members
um against um against entire societies
and certainly against um
against dissenters um but that this this
is happening
at least at this point absent um
anything emerging from the state in fact
you know there there are there are many
in you know and you know everyone knows
that they exist but you know there are
many among
um acquaintances and and friends of ours
even who
do think that fascism is coming and it's
and it's trump
right that that's that that is the big
threat to
democracy and the republic at this point
and
um it is it is certainly true that we
are no
fan of of the way that trump took
power and the kinds of ways that he
played people off one another
that were indeed destructive of
relationship and discourse
uh and and you know and for the most
part um you know we're just
we're not republicans and so mostly
don't agree with um
what his stated policies are although
there have been exceptions as we've
talked about
um on this podcast um but
a we are on the left and so critiquing
our own
is one of the things that we think is is
critical
but also it is true that um
we see the threat that is emerging
on and you know really depending on how
you count emerging or decades old now
well coming to fever pitch now
um on university campuses in corporate
boardrooms in cubicles in the media
in the arts you know across every domain
that you can imagine um that is
nominally on the left as a bigger threat
to democracy and the republic
than you know frankly a few well-armed
kooks on the right
all right so i still want to delve
further here because the idea that soft
totalitarianism
might be defined by non-state
totalitarianism
i believe there's something important
about this on the other hand
i can't look away from
the fact that i regard the state as
feeble and parasitized the corruption
of the american governmental structure
is one
in which corporate forces
effectively took it over so it's not a
strong
governing force what governs our lives
most directly
is whether or not you know twitter finds
a perspective
so abhorrent that it's going to shut it
down so
in some sense if you came at this as a
biologist or an anthropologist and you
said
governance is that which governs right
rather than governance is the thing with
the buildings that have the columns
right if governance is the thing that
governs
then governance has changed and this is
moving through the governance structure
right um and so to uh
to play devil's advocate here for a
moment uh i could see people arguing
that you are changing the definition of
governance just as the definition of
racism sexism and fascism has been
changed by
people on the other side well i'm trying
not to and
as you know i don't i don't i don't
think that critique is fair but i'd like
to hear you defend
i mean let's put it this way i'm sorting
it out in real time so
uh i want to know that i'm not doing
that also yeah um so
but you i think you said governance
governance is that which government
governance is that which governs which
seems
uh both total logical and therefore hard
to escape as
must be a definition that is at least
true even if it's not sufficient
no i would say you know um let's take
the british monarchy okay the british
monarchy does not govern
right it governs in as much as it
manages to fend off
um taxation and
you know demand a certain amount of
uh infrastructure to keep the monuments
alive but it is a ceremonial
apparatus even though it looks like a
governmental apparatus
from centuries back right in this case
what you have
is this case being the united states at
the present
we know empirically that the public will
does not have a strong influence it has
almost no influence in fact on
policy right we fight over policy we
battle at the ballot box over policy but
then the policy manages
not to serve any of us as it ser you
know or it accidentally serves us as it
serves the interests
of things that really do have influence
um and so
you know i mean there's no clear line
here does the government govern
yes in whose interest oh those that
corrupt it so it's a puppet
of something that governs right and that
puppet thing
is now going woke right so we are now
seeing
um these sort of self-imposed uh sets of
guidelines flowing through
you know corporate boards and then we
are seeing the government
um potentially being persuaded to
institute
uh you know quotas and things like this
and impose them on these corporations
and you know most importantly we see the
corporations
deciding the limits of actual speech can
you still say anything you want
sure you know in the confines of your
own home can you
say it where people are actually
listening well no um you know
twitter had you know decided to shut
down
twitter and facebook decided to shut
down this
expose of the hunter
biden ukraine business
this week on the basis that it was
somehow
uh faulty or dangerous which is
preposterous it was embarrassing to
a political entity that twitter and
facebook favor
um so we are seeing
you know i guess the other way i would
say it is that the founders
at the point that they were protecting
our ability to
gather and speak with each other and
uh voice opinions that were not popular
were worried about the state itself they
didn't understand that something would
evolve that would have
power that would dwarf the state that
would take over the state and therefore
the protections are inadequate and so
anyway
ultimately is there anything inherently
soft
about the totalitarianism that is moving
is it early in the trajectory and will
we laugh at the term
soft totalitarianism five years from now
when we've seen where it actually goes
well i don't i mean i don't think the
term is meant to imply that it's nicer
uh it's just that it's not and enforced
with the backing of military and like i
just made that up at the moment but you
know it's it's
it's different and this is one way of of
describing the difference
um and i do find that uh his
characterization drier's
characterization of it as a therapeutic
totalitarianism is actually even more
apt so he says um i i said already
um that he describes therapeutic
totalitarianism as
um hatred of dissenters from this
utopian ideology that comes in the guise
of helping and healing
right um but he's he specifically argues
that
therapy that the therapeutic mode is a
sort of post-modern mode of existence
which i think
is apt and
again this is written as a book quote
unquote for christian dissidents
and so he talks about religious man
giving way to psychological man
religious man in his definition
is living according to a belief in
transcendent principles that order human
life around communal purposes
right and psychological man believes
there's no transcendent order and life's
purpose is defined one's way
experimentally
and there's a way in which if you just
took that out of context entirely and
said okay psychological man there's no
transcendent order and life's purpose is
to find one's way experimentally
that sounds a lot like um something that
we believe
that you and i believe as people without
without without faith
and um who do understand evolution to
explain
um the current forms of life on earth
however the description of religious man
um if you if you read it metaphorically
is also something that we hold very very
dear
which is that according if i just take
out
um transcendent for the moment lives
according to belief in principles that
order human life around communal
purposes
that this that this is absolutely a huge
huge value in human life and it is a
loss that we have seen
as modernity has increasingly valued the
individual and the individual's
comfort and pleasure and thrills
over anything that might in any way
constrain those comforts and pleasures
and thrills
such as religion okay but also
family um also community
also just anything that reveals that you
are in fact
answerable to a greater good that may be
of your own choosing
in your in your friend group or um not
as much of your own
choosing in your family and this is not
this is not to say that people don't
sometimes
um you know get a draw terrible hand and
are born into terrible families from
which they must escape and therefore
have no option
to be part of a family um that is that
is wonderful and loving but most of us
aren't in that situation
and the idea that we can and indeed that
we must overthrow family
as a constraint that it is from the past
and we are
interested only in moving forward and
finding new ways that are filled with
rainbows and unicorns in this utopian
future
well it's it's not just delusional but
it's dangerous
so um and we're still
let me just share a little bit more
before you before you riff again because
we've gotten through very little of this
so far um
in communist russia drier reports um
parents were choosing to avoid what he
calls contamination
the humanities by encouraging children
to study natural sciences
this sounds a little bit like what is
going on with critical race theory
and intersectionality in the modern
academy
except of course in modernity in modern
times we have
uh this ideology has has marched right
into the natural sciences has declared
that uh male and female are
social constructs and don't really
differ at all and um you know even even
the natural sciences aren't safe
not even it's not even limited to the
natural sciences even math
right even even math even math um so
um so it's in some ways we've gone
even farther than uh what was being seen
in totalitarian communist russia
um the he drier was told by some of the
people he was interviewing that you know
essays must conform to a communist point
of view
well that sounds familiar doesn't it
anyone who's been in
uh high school or college or knows
someone who has
in the last uh 10 years knows very well
that in some classes
in some fields there is one and only one
uh perspective that you are allowed to
take all this talk of multiple lenses
that the supposedly you know liberal
perspective allows
well only up to a point only if uh
you know only if you're writing about
something that you yourself may have
experienced but in terms of
the conclusions that you come to uh
really in many fields there's only one
conclusion you're allowed to come to
yeah um so this raises a bunch of
different points and i i don't know
uh i don't know where all you're headed
but i do think
a we have to understand something i now
hear
the this talk of communism and where we
are with respect to this new
trajectory and i cannot help there's a
part of me that hears it the way i would
have heard it at 18.
right and to hear and share i mean i
think i know i knew you at 18. yeah how
would you afford it at 18. i would have
heard it as
uh um a lot of
breathless fearful uh
over hyping of concerns that were really
very
scary remote right um and
i think the thing is now um i'm
beginning to understand
i do think that what we heard earlier in
our lives
was very overblown and of course a
tremendous amount of
harm was done fighting communism in the
u.s
right people who weren't communists or
people who were sort of nominally
interested in communism but hadn't done
anything wrong were
obviously punished formally and
informally but
but that said i now think i
appreciate something about why
communism causes people to lose their
minds
especially people who've seen what it
does right and so
we have heard many people say that you
know communism always ends in
starvation and gulags and i've begun to
wonder if in fact it starts with them
rather than
ends with them and if the reason isn't
pretty obvious from our own
discipline okay so let me just interject
one thing here that happens to be in my
in my notes here that um
totalitarians exert a tremendous amount
of effort to control the common
narrative
and you know a point to which we have we
have spoken before and will speak
a lot again that we need we need strong
true amazing narratives that we can
point to that can become our myths
upon which with which we can build an an
excellent world that is it is fair for
all
um but mulan kundera specifically
has spoken to the danger of forgetting
one's past which i think is is a is a
big part of what we're experiencing here
is that almost no one knows history no
no one including our generation really
was taught history well
uh and um drear paraphrase in kundera
says nobody defends gulags today
but the world remains full of suckers
for the false utopian promises
that bring gulags into existence right
and people are erasing it's not even
just forgetting right so kundera deals
very well with the issue of forgetting
and actually erasing there's a vivid uh
image that has a member uh who has
behaved badly
physically erased from a painting i
believe or you know painted over
but in any case um the
there are a number of important things
one i believe that it is
simply the failure of group selection
that forces totalitarians especially of
a communist
ilk to engage in this totalitarian
overreach in other words to the extent
that people have any freedom at all um
communism is not game theoretically
stable therefore the way you would
stabilize it or attempt to stabilize it
has to do with
penalizing people who act on the basis
of reasonable incentives right you have
to reschedule
their incentives so that they behave you
know
uh for the same reason that a prisoner
or a slave behaves because the
punishment for not behaving is so great
um so anyway that hazard is is very
large now
i want to return to something else that
you said though you were talking about
whether people need to believe something
larger and i've heard a number of people
talk about this maybe most recently
douglas murray who is i believe a
non-believer
but who regards religion as essential
because of effectively what happens when
people don't have something larger than
themselves to believe in and so
if this is all right what you've said
and what douglas has said is correct
but it if it is also correct that people
like you and and
and i um get along without
a belief in a supernatural higher order
right that there is something that we
have supplanted then this raises the
question
of is there so i have the sense that
basically
you remove the belief in a higher power
right and it takes the safety off the
gun but it doesn't fire the gun
right so the gun becomes dangerous at
the point that you don't have that
higher order you can
fall into one of these false ideologies
and you can end up doing horrible things
um because it basically slots in
where you know a belief in something
larger would go
but it doesn't have to be that way so
i'm wondering if we might
actually just tell the story of dining
with a malagasy family
in southern madagascar a judge
and her family many years ago would have
been 1993 our first trip to madagascar
um you know you know the story oh sure
of course yeah do you want to tell it or
something
i'm sure this is always a danger when
the story is that old how much will we
will we agree on exactly what happened
but okay let me let me just set up that
we had been traveling
across the southern half of madagascar
for in my rendering in the book that i
wrote about
uh six years that we've been traveling
six years yes it was we traveled 670
kilometers if
if memory serves and it took 67 hours to
travel so we were going at a rocking
speed of about 10 kilometers an hour
which is about six miles an hour four
weeks endless
endless endless in the back of a truck
that had
hard wooden benches that had been
built into the back of this truck this
is a common mode of transportation
madagascar
taxi bruce um there so we were all
nighting all day
and um the particular vehicle had a
light bulb
suspended from the roof by a wire that
swung back and forth all
night that they wouldn't even turn off
while you were trying to sleep and one
tape of maligzi pop music on loop one
song
one song over and over again and over
again
and you know there were people getting
so there were chickens that would land
on your shoulder
there was breakdowns there it was it was
endless
but we befriended a young malagasy boy
really who was
um very unlike anyone in royal
madagascar to travel that far
who was going i think from his secondary
school back home
for a break right uh we befriended him
and at the point that we stopped i don't
know if we befriended emory
took pity on us it may have been that
yeah um
but at the very the very last stop
before we were there and we just hit and
hit a paved road and it was like 30 more
kilometers they're like we're here
like we're we're not going anywhere for
the night
and we i think i may have burst into
tears which is unlike me
um yes it is yeah um anyway by the time
we finally ultimately got to our final
destination
um he had long since said please when we
do get there if we do get there
um please come dine with my family and
me and so
we stayed with them no that wasn't the
the penultimate night
um at the judge's house in uh what would
have been for
i can't remember um or if it's not the
one at the northern
no that's diego suarez his fort defense
is southern okay
um we know we'd gotten cleaned up uh
we'd gone over to this nice dinner
at then it was it was a female judge in
madagascar and her husband i think was a
general contractor and you know this
madagascar is often um at the
ranked as the as the least prosperous
country
on the planet like the lowest gdp all of
this and they had a
solidly middle class life going and we
were having
a very nice meal you know i spoke some
french
which is the the main language that
people in the middle class and
in madagascar speak although malagasy is
the main language
um and they spoke a little bit of
english as well and then
during the meal during the meal we were
talking and they were
curious about us of course um i assume
nobody in that family had
been off island yeah i don't think so um
not sure of that but i think so
in any case they were curious about us
and uh they were as
is so often the case they were so
welcoming and generous and
and decent and they asked us about our
uh religious beliefs and we
uh maybe without quite enough caution
coughed up uh that we didn't really have
a religious belief
that we had you know historical
backgrounds that traced their roots to
these traditions but
didn't believe anything ourselves and
there was
this kind of uh inability to know what
to do with what had just been
said and there was they became worried
about us well i don't think they did but
there was
they voiced concern about well okay
if we take you at your word and you
really don't believe anything
then what prevents you from doing x y z
how is it that you live good lives how
is it that you will continue to live
good lives right which turns out to be a
better question than you would think
that's a terrific question yeah um and
so the answer is
something you know i i think the answer
in our case at least
if we can use our own minds as a place
that we have
some access i believe what we've done
is we have figured out what higher
purpose
could be constructed from a secular
foundation
in other words i don't think most people
can handle
the um the existential of existentialism
of
a lack of higher external purpose
but for those who can get through that
part you know in one way or another
there are things that you can pursue as
if they are
ultimate and they may not be um but it
doesn't have to drive you crazy
but that said i you know i guess the
real question is
is there i'm i shudder every time
somebody makes the claim that we have to
have religion or else people go crazy
and do terrible things because if that's
true
then we're stuck in a very bad bind
which is that we are not
um we are not getting any less
capable of understanding what the
universe is made of which means that the
necessity of god to the explanation of
what we are and how we got here and what
it means
is um ever more remote so
are we just going to continue to go
crazy till we destroy ourselves or
can people actually get over the
existential crisis
and come up with things that work as
well
or better well and you know and so in
drears book i don't think that there is
really an invocation of of god per se
there is certainly invocation of faith
and belief
but mostly it is a
way of organizing your life in line
with principles that have been honorable
and served truth and and justice and
beauty in the past and we see no reason
to think that they have stopped doing so
if you if you and your family
and the community with whom you choose
to
to interact um are all also abiding by
similar principles
and so it's you know it's it is not
primarily about
um is there god it is it is about the
all of the other traditions that the
religion is based on right so if i can
go back to the
uh what i think is a fair
characterization of
at least the jewish diaspora and
actually i would think
most of israeli society too um there
is something that occurs where
religion is practiced and nobody
is all that interested in getting you to
unpack
your level of belief right the point is
do you behave
actually it matches very well what i
heard uh jordan peterson once say which
got him
in lots of trouble in certain quarters i
think it was actually during the debates
in vancouver
where um he was asked if he believed
in a supernatural god and he said
uh i behave as if i do right which i
made perfect sense to me what he was
saying but
was taken by some to indicate a kind of
hypocrisy or
vagueness or something like that but i
guess the question is
if it was true that jews were
anti-fragile because of all the stuff
that happens every time
the center collapses and that one of the
things that you do is you teach people
how not to shed their traditions because
those traditions are serving
unstated goals one of the things you
might do
is provide a kind of don't ask don't
tell
over faith and you know that does seem
to be the nature of it
right people have complex relationships
and it's very hard to know exactly what
they believe nor does it matter
yeah that's right
um okay so many places to go
here uh let's
we've already talked a little bit about
freedom being responsibility
responsibility for and towards rather
than responsibility from
and um uh drier argues that
um too often the secular liberal ideal
of freedom in the west is about
freedom from things as opposed to uh
being bringing with it a responsibility
for and towards
those to whom you are um you are bonded
with
and tied to and indebted to and
responsible for
and again from father kalakovic whose
name i am probably
still mispronouncing um he he has sort
of a three-part
instruction see judge act
c which means be awake to the realities
around you
judge soberly discern what those
realities mean in light of what you know
and he would have it especially in light
of christian teachings
and act to resist evil and um
that's not to say that sometimes um
passive disobedience
or um quiet disagreement isn't
the the best move you know you we we we
are not
instructed by this book or by you know
honorable dissident christians in
general
um that you must always take a stand and
put your life on the line every time you
see
um you see one of these things happening
um
but this this man who said see judge act
um oh my god the cat just did something
very bad
um see judge act
um he succeeded almost instantly
as he was moving uh as he was
as he had escaped the gestapo he he'd
been
on the run as an anti-fascist and um
he created this community of trust and
mutual friendship from a diverse group
of people because
because you can right because it is
actually possible that when you engage
with people as individuals
regardless of their background
regardless of what
they describe to you as their
capabilities or their beliefs
and you know almost everyone can
actually can be reached
and you know we saw this in our careers
as professors
in the classroom in the field in labs
that
almost every human being is simply
looking for connection is looking for
someone to
to see them and to look at them and say
i know something real about you you know
show a little bit of respect and learn
their names first but then also know
something
real about them that isn't somewhat
arbitrary and
um and make a connection and
gosh that's almost all it takes and so
much of that is missing from from a
moderate the modern ideology this modern
ideology is based
primarily on hate it's about what you're
resisting only as opposed to what you're
for
um so we'll come back to that but let me
let me let's
spend just a little bit of time talking
about family talking about privacy
and a little bit more on community so
family um vaxlav bender
who was a primary leader of the
resistance to communism in the czech
half
of czechoslovakia believe that the
family is the bedrock of civilization
and must be nurtured and protected at
all costs and he saw communism in his
country directly threaten the family
he wrote an essay in 88 called the
family in the totalitarian state
which defends yes the christian idea of
family
on three bases fellowship of love the
gift of freedom but again freedom
which involves responsibility rather
than freedom from responsibility
and the dignity of the individual within
family fellowship
quote in practically all other social
roles were replaceable and can be
relieved of them
whether rightly or wrongly and i want to
read the rest of this quote here
bender writes in this 1988 essay
in practically all other social roles we
are replaceable and can be relieved of
them whether rightly or wrongly
however such a cold calculation of
justice does not reign between husband
and wife
between children and parents but rather
the law of love
even where love fails completely and
with all that accompanies that failure
the appeal of shared responsibility for
mutual salvation remains
preventing us from giving up on unworthy
sons cheating wives and daughtering
fathers
this is this is what is meant by
responsibility for
freedom um involves responsibility
involves obligation
uh a completely frankly anarchist
liberation from all that has come before
including all relationships that have
come before
is a descent very quickly into a horror
that no one wants to live with
so um i want to try to i hope i don't
regret attempting this but
okay there's something about
step into our evolutionary lens for a
second here
step behind the evolutionary lens you've
got
lineage lineage being the point of
uh evolution's point which is neither
good nor bad but nonetheless it is the
organizing principle we would argue
for what it is we are to do family
is the limits of lineage that you
actually have contact with
that can be extended family and in some
cultures it can be very extended
it can then be you know modernity can
wreck extended family and it can reduce
family to the nuclear version
the family in question is in some sense
the christian version because the old
testament is not a monogamous document
the new testament is
and so in some sense we have been handed
a version of family that has been
altered by modernity altered by
somewhat ancient belief structures but
is stable
for evolutionary reasons what stabilizes
it metaphorical beliefs about a higher
ultimate purpose when you can't state
the actual purpose which is
the longevity of lineage well but the
other thing that stabilizes
is exactly what i was just reading that
um that within
family the social roles aren't
replaceable right we can't just be
relieved of them
this is exactly what i'm saying is that
to behave as if those
are permanent connections
is a literal understanding of something
beneath them that until very recently we
couldn't say anything about
right which is your genetic lineage and
so
in any case the point is when somebody
sits down with pen and paper and says i
have a better way
we'll dissolve that stuff we'll
collectivize everything we'll distribute
it beautifully
right what they are in effect doing is
arguing an evolutionarily unstable
strategy
how will they seek to stabilize it with
violence even if they don't know that
that's what they're advocating at the
point they decide this is the way
forward
they are guaranteeing that they will
have to avail themselves of violence and
totalitarianism
in order to stabilize it because it is
inherently an evolutionarily
unstable strategy and has no way of
maintaining itself
absent force and violence exactly so for
those few of you who are tracking
the fact that david sloane wilson and i
are on a collision course about group
selection versus what i call lineage
selection this is the point
group selection is unstable and
therefore requires some sort of
force to make it work lineage selection
is the thing that flows under
all of these systems that have worked
and lasted and so
the you know the ultimate metaphorical
truths that stabilize the underlying
lineage phenomenon that we can't exactly
describe is the key thing that is being
challenged and
in any case we have to figure out how to
repel that challenge
without um i think resorting to a
a primitive mindset about the
supernatural
good um so
i think you know we have already spoken
plenty in past
episodes of this podcast about how it is
that the new ideology the ascendant
ideology
is appearing to go after family but let
me just
give a provide a few examples here for
those who
imagine that we are uh speaking
feverishly
and uh and and making things up uh so
uh this is again bender in this 1988
essay writes a left-wing intellectual
terror
achieved what it wanted marriage and the
family became extremely problematic
institutions
interesting by the way that problematic
shows up as the word there in 1988
um so i found for instance sec just
quickly put this on screen this 1994
article published in the history of
european ideas which is a history a
review of marx
engels and the abolition of the family
uh so that's just
a piece of of scholarship describing um
how how marxism actually argues exactly
what you just said it did
uh black lives matter the organization
rather than the the true sentiment which
is supposedly what the organization is
based on but we have argued i think
convincingly that it's not uh has gone
after the family
they have since pulled it from their
site but in episode 25
which which was also clipped out
we pointed out that this was on their
site we
black lives matter disrupt the western
prescribed nuclear family structure
requirement by supporting each other
as extended families and villages that
collectively care for one another etc
etc
uh there is a
truly awful book called full surrogacy
now
by one sophie lewis who argues what
really matters to me is the abolishment
of the isoli
isolated privatization of human misery
the radical scarcity and overwork that
is born of the logic of marriage and a
family
uh incidentally she uh during this year
during the coronavirus pandemic wrote a
piece that was headlined the coronavirus
crisis shows it's time to abolish the
family
when in fact if at any moment it should
have been more obvious that intact
families were
useful in actually dealing with the
chaos
that has ensued um this should have been
the one
and then there's a piece i'm just not
gonna link to all of these but there's a
piece published in commune at the very
end of last year
called six steps to abolish the family
and this is just the tip of the iceberg
it's
it's
all over the place in the modern
ideology
um so benda
further argues in this essay quote in a
society of atomized individuals
as communist czechoslovakia was it was
important for ordinary people to come
together and to be reminded of one
another's existence
so that speaks to the importance of
community that goes beyond family but
before we
um before we i guess before we move over
into talking about community a little
bit
uh let me say a couple more things
about um how
how believing in your family and
trusting your family
has been useful so we must actually
trust our children and tell them the
truth and much about modern parenting
suggests doing exactly the opposite
protecting them from all things that are
difficult and
lying to them when it seems easier or
won't hurt them in the moment
and this renders them helpless and
hopeless and frankly incompetent and
they grow up into
well anarchists actually so um
again i will butcher this man's name i
apologize
as a hungarian boy scout thomas sally's
father had been linked to a typewriter
on which someone composed anti-soviet
propaganda
the year was 1946 and the red army
occupied hungary
all the scouts connected to the
typewriter suffered punishment
death exile or in the case of the elder
sally
in tournament without charge in a prison
camp
in 1963 less than 20 years later
when thomas was only seven years old he
came home from school and told his
father how the soviet army had liberated
their nation
he said boy sit down thomas remembers
he began to tell me stories about the 56
uprising and soviet invasion
he told me the truth and when he
finished he warned me never to talk
about that at school
hamas glances down at the floor of his
budapest living room
we have so many problems today because
fathers never talked to their sons as my
father did to me in 1963.
long before you and i thought that there
was something potentially very dangerous
on the horizon here
we without actually ever talking about
it in advance
parented our children by speaking to
them from
the time that they were far too young to
understand from
when they were pre-lingual as if they
were smart and capable human beings who
would come to understand what we were
saying to them
we trusted them to be reasonable we
trusted them
to be honest and honorable we taught
them
to assess rules and to obey good ones
and to undermine bad ones and sometimes
we will all make mistakes about which
rules are bad and which rules are good
but not simply to trust on the basis
that someone told you you needed to do
something
this points out why i think
that is so important not only that that
our boys now 14 and 16 are growing into
you know anti-fragile strong
compassionate
brilliant young men but that they
actually have the courage of their
convictions
and when they don't know something they
know that they don't know it and are
willing to say so
and um they know from all the way back
that we trusted them to be
to be honest and to be courageous so if
i can um
just glance at this from a slightly
different angle
maybe it's not but the
there is something about a proper
familial relationship in which
there can be a kind of candor
because there is no optionality about
the relationship itself yeah and so the
idea
you know and if you think about you know
the the stasi
or whatever and they're
terrorizing of people by getting them to
rat on each other and things it breaks
this
fundamental bond but it is normal and
natural
for your family members to be the only
people who can voice certain things in
an era where certain
false ideas are spread as if they are
truth
the place where you will hear actually
that's not right is at home
and this has been true forever right
um and not just from parents from
siblings from
right exactly your cousins from whoever
it is that is that is in your home with
you
anybody who doesn't have an option and
this becomes very different when you may
not know your cousins right when
you only gather at certain ceremonial
uh phenomena or whatever it may be
but it is vitally important that you
recognize that there's a certain amount
of lying that goes on
in the world you know it's automatic
that there would be for
all sorts of different reasons for
business reasons for reasons of
you know people trying to get into each
other's pants there's all kinds of lying
out there
where can you depend on people not to do
that well you should be able to depend
on them not to do it at home
yes and yes you know so for example
um you know the idea that masculinity is
toxic
and that you shouldn't engage in it
right because it's just bad
right well that could result if you were
a boy and nobody told you the truth
about it
that could result in you weakening
yourself and emasculating yourself
thinking that that might be the only way
for you to have
you know a proper romantic relationship
and then you're gonna find out what oh
women don't like weak men
so you've gotten rid of whatever
strength you had that might have been
attractive and
so in any case somebody has to sit you
down and say look i know that that's
what people are saying but it's garbage
and here's why yeah and strength is not
violence
those are two different things right
women don't want violent men but they
also don't want weak men
right and in fact strong men don't have
to engage in violence very frequently
the point is they
they have the restraint and the
discipline to deal with it so
um the the point though is that
going after the nuclear family is
necessary
in order to disrupt the imagine that
every household
somebody is saying actually you know
that's [ __ ] you got to say it
outside but here
you don't have to say that because we
know better that would weaken
the revolution so the revolution has to
break apart the family or render its
suspect or something
in order to do what it does you go after
the family and you go after men
and you've done a lot of the job that
you need to do of what you're trying to
do
is weaken the links between people
and this also explains why we are seeing
such a heavy concentration of this
in schools of ed in schools themselves
and especially
schools where we're dealing with the
very young children because the
complexity of raising children where you
tell them the truth at home
and then wondering if they're going to
say something at school that is going to
reveal that your family isn't on board
yeah right
is yeah now and they're testifying to
say the least i think it's not
from this uh quote that i'm about to
read but um
drear also reports in the book um how
you know in in many of the totalitarian
regimes of course
schools are used as replacements for
family
and and students are taught that when
they
have when they hear a discrepancy
between what they hear at home what they
hear in school
they must trust the state they must
trust the school and in this case
in you know 21st century weird countries
including the united states
it's not about the state versus the
family but it is about the schools
versus the family
and um and you know the schools are
well captured they they truly are with
this ideology
so uh maria komaromi who is a catholic
teacher in budapest says
it's no accident that every dictatorship
always tries to break down the family
because it's in the family that you get
the strength to be able to fight
you have the feeling that they have your
backs you can go out into the world and
face anything
it is just as true today as it was under
communism she said that to drear in
modern times
so i would say that this is exactly
right and it strangely points to
well it's not strange it won't be
strange to you or me but it seems to
point to
uh a danger in two distinct modern
parenting styles that would seem to be
at odds but they're actually two
very bad sides of a bad of a bad coin
which is that helicopter parenting uh
which protects children from
all risk and insult uh and would seem
to uh you know then creates the need for
safe spaces
and you know creates creates young
adults who are
in you know adult and body only and
really have never experienced anything
to push back against to learn how to be
in the world in combination with
letting babies cry themselves to sleep
and
alone and putting them on schedules
right so that's
that's equally insane right a tiny
a tiny child who does not yet
have relationships in the world who does
not yet know that there is anyone or
anything to trust
needs the connection more than anything
so that once
once that child knows that they have one
hopefully two parents hopefully more
even
but who 100 have their back who are with
them all the time
who will pick them up if they cry and
who are not going to be
bullied by them who are not going to let
this child be a terrorist but
um who are going to 100 have their back
then
very early you can let that child start
to go out and take risks
and you know and handle knives in the
kitchen and go out on a bike ride
at ages that most weird parents most
modern american parents wouldn't imagine
letting their children do
but um but children become capable very
very quickly
but only if they 100 know
that you that there is a hopefully two
parents
absolutely with love and adoration for
them watching their back who will step
in if they
all can to help them if they get into
trouble so i think this is a brilliant
and really important
connection i had not not understood this
before but
the so it's not even know that their
parents will it's below
knowing yeah right attachment which is
formed so
early is the basically wired in
sense of security that actually allows
you to be bold and face danger because
you know that you can always
go back to the thing that remains true
and that raised you so breaking
attachment
with the you know rather insane and
counter evolutionary belief that somehow
you must not
be too responsive to your infant um
lest you you know give them the
expectation that they're going to be
taken care of i wouldn't want to cuddle
the baby
right that nutty
uh belief structure which was so
prevalent uh
in the 60s and 70s
is clearly connected in some way
you've got people who are alien to their
own families
right which makes them more susceptible
to the message
that's coming from outside that they are
entitled to certain things
and what is it they're being told that
they're entitled to they're untold
they're being told that they
are entitled to be comfortable and feel
safe at all times which is not life
right the ability to be durable and to
know how you know to not be paralyzed by
sense of discomfort or a momentary lack
of safety
is essential to being a functional adult
and so basically the idea is we've
hobbled these kids we've broken their
sense of where they might be safe we've
then externally allowed them to be told
that they're entitled to be safe at all
times and the fact that they
are constantly feeling jeopardized is
somebody else's responsibility and that
they are
in a position to demand redress now it's
a
um it's failures all the way down yeah
it is and you know i have to imagine
that most of these things came together
in uh one ugly
disastrous package by accident but now
that it's here
wow you can see it yeah no it's it's uh
it's it's truly awful and um in part
what we see right now
in the modern instantiation of the sort
of revolutionary attack on the family
is predicated on the fact
actually that most family many families
already had this destruction at their
base that they had this
crazy combination of make sure the
babies are
effectively abandoned so that they don't
have safety
and then create a dynamic where
you keep them from all risk once they're
old enough where they should be
experiencing
risk like you know of course at some
level some people will
will grow up and decide that the family
needs to be abolished well yes those
kinds of families should because
that really doesn't deserve the name
that you know that that kind of
parenting
is so confused and frankly so
so dangerous to children that it it that
should be
um a thing of the past
okay uh yep uh we have we have just a
few more things that we want to
we want to get through um okay so with
regard to
community um
actually let's let's let's move on first
to
speak to here another another quotation
from
this drew your book live not by lies
here is a
if i can find it
yeah this is a disillusioned czech
communist whose husband was murdered in
1952
um speaking uh in modern times i believe
it is not hard for a totalitarian regime
to keep people ignorant
once you relinquish your freedom for the
sake of understood necessity
for party discipline for conformity with
the regime for the greatness and glory
of the fatherland or for any of the
substitutes that you are so convincingly
offered
you cede your claim to the truth slowly
drop by drop your life begins to ooze
away just as surely as if you had
slashed your wrists
you have voluntarily condemned yourself
to helplessness so
why uh we are asked after
hearing that um do people surrender the
moral responsibility to be honest which
is is a responsibility that i think we
should we all should feel a moral
responsibility to be honest
well in some cases it's out of misplaced
idealism
it can be out of a simple desire to
transgress and destroy
that's the anarchism um
and it can also be out of a greater
greater hatred
for others than love for the truth and i
do think that this
the hatred at the base of so much of
what we're seeing is
is critical that there is and
you know this but i've been getting
these texts from the democrats
right telling me that i really really
really need to donate and
and and vote and um you and i both have
been responding to these people and you
know maybe we'll share our little text
exchanges at some point not not today
um but in the latest one that i got
yeah i said you know trump did this and
trump did that and
um you know you need to go out and
defeat trump and i wrote back and i said
i understand
what you're arguing i should push
against but you've given me literally no
reason
to vote for provide me one reason to
vote for
as opposed to vote against i'm listening
i literally ended with i'm listening and
you know i got nothing back in that case
crickets in some of these cases i have
gotten an exchange um
with with some of these some of these
people
um who are who are writing who are you
know speaking on behalf of democrats
trying to get other you know registered
democrats to
to to get out the vote and um
it's at the moment it's so based on
hatred
and it's like love is so far from
people's minds and
even put aside love but like what what
are you what are you fighting for like
what
what what is it that we are uh that we
are fighting for so let me just before
you speak
say um that hannah arendt you know
amazing um historian of totalitarianism
uh wrote uh that in pre-totalitarian
states
hating respectable society was so
narcotic
that elites were willing to accept quote
monstrous forgeries and historiography
for the straight for the sake of
striking back at those who in their view
had excluded the underprivileged and
oppressed from the memory of mankind
and um you know c as
item number one at the top of the list
in people's minds at the moment of
course the 1619 project
just a complete revisionist history that
is about
divisiveness and hatred and it's
um i'm sure there are some true things
in it but it's mostly
simply not true and yet it is being
it is being lifted up as this amazing
piece of scholarship and beauty and the
way that we should teach our children
about the origins of the united states
when it should be actually exactly the
opposite and it seems to be frankly
and everything i've seen from the the
author of it
seems to be based not in any desire to
heal
to build to create
but out of a sense of hatred and
divisiveness and an interest in
destruction
so i think above all else it's not that
it's
false it's verificationist right it
basically compiles
pieces to paint a false picture yeah um
out of things some
many of which are true but um i want to
kind of synthesize the the model that i
think you're building here because it's
um it's really quite quite good
we've hobbled people right we hobbled
them in part
just by throwing a totally novel
world at them and them failing to know
what's actually good and what feels good
but is bad and
yeah um so they're they're hobbled
in due course they are uh
badly miseducated and among the worst
ways they are educated is that they are
not given
a self-motivational capacity that would
cause them to be able to figure out how
to accomplish things so they're always
waiting to be told
what to do and what they're told to do
is of no value and
is basically you know you spend your
time doing somebody else's bidding
right right so it's not so much anger at
other people or maybe it's a
flavor of anger it's resentment of those
who are more capable and that
resentment then results in
a listening so these people
we all have the experience of
advertisers telling us oh
there's something wrong with you and we
have the solution here it is you just
you 1995
three times a month whatever it is that
they you know whatever it is that they
want us to do
right so they're using our
dissatisfaction to get us to buy stuff
right in this case the woke revolution
is using people's very understandable
dissatisfaction with a life that isn't
coherent and that you know they're
constantly
harming themselves and they're being
told this isn't your fault which it
isn't
um and we have the solution right in
fact those people who are doing better
than you this is their fault
yes right okay so that's nonsense what
are you supposed to do
well surrender all of your tools
right two plus two does not equal what
you were told it equals right you can't
even rely
on that stuff but listen to us we've got
tools they work
just go with us but the point is it is
it's not even learned helplessness it's
a step
beyond learned helplessness it's
cultivated helplessness
right snake oil helplessness yes it's uh
it's some sort of exponential
self-inflicted expanding helplessness
that causes you to have no
option once you've signed up with this
thing and given up your tools
effectively
you're just gonna ride that thing you
know you've you've you've signed up for
it because you don't you know you're
like out of at sea
with no you know craft that you could
leave the boat and you know set off on
your own you're just committed
and once you've given up on those tools
there's no going back
well especially if it takes you know if
you know a you forget how to use them
and b you stop being educated in
anything other than woke ideology
then you know of course all you can be
is a foot soldier in that battle and
you know you're hoping that once the
spoils are collected they will be
distributed to you which of course they
won't because the game theory
suggests that what will happen is that
the
the the coalition that has assembled to
win those spoils is going to break down
as soon as the spoils are won
and it's going to become uh you know
crony capitalist at best right it's not
going to be distributed in the way
people think
those people who were foot soldiers are
actually suckers no
of course it won't um
okay let's talk about um privacy for a
moment
uh actually no but first let's just
finish up we were we were just talking
about
um what a former prisoner of conscience
in russia
um told dreher christian's need is
something he called a golden dream
okay something to live for a conception
of hope
he said you can't just be against
everything bad you have to be for
something good
otherwise you can get really dark and
crazy
and and
later in the book drier is talking to a
central leader of the second wave of the
slovak underground church who's now in
his 70s and he says
quote when i talk to young people today
i tell them they have it harder than we
did in a way it is harder to tell who is
the enemy
i tell them that what is crucial is to
stay true to yourself true to your
conscience and also to be in community
with other like-minded people who share
the faith
we were saved by small communities
and i feel like we're kind of coming
full circle here but
it strikes me that some of what has
happened what you were just talking
about
is that we have handed all the tools of
resistance to people
with nothing actually to resist like
they're they
they they were harmed by a
bunch of things over which they had no
control
but pretending that the people who have
the stuff
are the people who left them without any
tools or
any ability to modulate their own moods
is is wrong and so you know you have
you have these sort of historical tools
of resistance like
like blog posts that look like they
might be like sama's dot
and looking around and not knowing who
the enemy is and
um imagining therefore that you have to
find one and the enemy is you know
you like you must be the enemy and you
know we we saw that
three and a half years ago on on the
campus where we then were
um and this the lack of community
that people have is is
terrifying it was very bad before 2020
that people raised with helicopter
parents and on screens all the time
had an easier time engaging through
screens rather than in real
in real flesh and blood and of course
the lockdowns
um that um are persisting in most places
in
in some form or another have made it
even harder to come together in
community
but i would argue that we are actually
at particular risk right now
because shared visceral experience
is a huge part of what bonds people of
what brings people together and
in part we just don't even have the
scientific understanding or the language
of
exactly what all that is but we all know
that a conversation in flesh and blood
is not the same as a zoom call
zoom calls cannot replace visceral
flesh and blood shared space in a room
conversation
uh and so right now who is allowed who's
allowed that
it's the people who are spilling onto
the streets protesting and then
and then some fraction of those people
who are writing they are the ones then
who are establishing right now their own
history and their own community
and the rest of us are watching on a
horror
or ignoring them but we aren't also
managing to create our own community
because many of us are actually engaging
in the social distancing that we are
being told
that we must and it is creating
potentially a real asymmetry
in terms of what history is being is is
happening right now
and what history will be capable of
being told because the people coming
together in community
do not have all of our best interests at
heart we need
shared experience we need shared
community we need shared history and we
mostly are
not managing to build that right now
we're not and
uh if i can link that back up to what
you were talking about with respect to
family
there's a way in which modern
sensibilities about
romance are getting in the way here
because you know in the world from which
we emerged
you for very easily understood reasons
ended up finding a partner and bonding
yourself to them
and the production of children
especially production of children early
in life
results in a phenomenon this is going to
sound counterintuitive but
a partnership a man and a woman who
produce offspring
though they are not blood relatives of
each other are
effectively blood relatives of each
other related through their children
right you become blood relatives with
somebody when you produce children with
them so the idea
that the point of life is now very
remote from the production of children
means that to the extent that people
have those partnerships they're
much closer to friendships than family
relationships
people are you know experimenting with
all kinds of
new configurations and none of it's
going to be
stable so in one sense i wonder if some
of the insanity that we're hearing
from otherwise reasonable young people
is actually the result of the fact that
at the end of the day
you don't even have that one person with
whom you can be candid about what you
actually think
because you're not related by something
you know as thick as blood yeah no i i
that's
that's important um here we've got
just one uh one more quote from a woman
who
whose name may be pronounced ramazuska
probably not
an 80 year old uh quote grand dom of
anti-communist resistance who is
critical in the solidarity trade
unionist trade union movement in poland
who sees the danger of soft
totalitarianism coming fast and urges
young people to get off the internet and
get together
face to face to build resistance quote
as i see it this is the core this is the
essence of everything right now
form these communities and networks of
communities whatever kind of communities
you can imagine
you don't have to be prepared to give
your life for the other person but you
do have to have something
in common and to do things together do
things together
yeah right we need to be doing things
together and
um god there's a ton more but let me
just
the one thing that we haven't spoken to
yet at all here
is the question of privacy so drear
devotes an entire chapter to
what he calls capitalism awoke and
watchful and
um basically it is it is certainly true
and anyone who's read
any any of the relevant literature or
knows any of the relevant
history knows that to be free to speak
the truth you have to create for
yourself a zone of privacy
that isn't violent you you need the
privacy to
to think without anyone looking into
your thoughts and to speak
where people whom you don't want
listening can't listen
and uh into that into that truth that
that
universal um never will change human
truth
we have smart speakers right which
apparently over 25
of americans have invited smart speakers
speakers into their homes
uh for convenience because it's nice to
be able to say
hey alexa put grapes on the list or
whatever it is we you know
we we don't we haven't we shuddered to
think when they came out
and um i think you've been to one
of our children's friends houses once
where you reported that they were
they were there and came out kind of you
know
shuddering afterwards going i didn't
actually know that we knew people who
had those things in their homes
they are potentially so dangerous
yes on that topic i would just amend
what you said slightly
alexa please put anti-racist grapes on
the list
yes yes yes thanks alex
did i get that right alexa right yeah i
don't know yeah i guess
um and you know add
to that uh polls now suggest that
millennials and gen z
um customers are especially prone to
seeing their consumer expenditures as
part of creating a socially conscious
personal brand identity
so this is human being as consumer
this you know ad add to the fact
that these are kids often raised on
legal drugs that prevent them from
understanding their own moods or forming
their own identities who've been
protected from all risk and danger and
intrigue by their parents who've been
hiding behind screens their entire lives
because at first they were
cheap babysitters then they became safer
ways to engage socially than actually
risking
a one-on-one or real group interaction
and now you have of course the fact that
they are seen
by by market america
by by corporate america mostly as
uh organisms with money to spend
and how do you how do you profit most
off of such an individual
you make them view themselves uh
primarily through
uh the the branding the branding lens
who you know what kind of person am i
i'm a person with an iphone
what kind of person am i i'm a person
who aspires to drive a
tesla right and you know who who wears
these kinds of shoes and those kinds of
glasses
on all of this and that
is far older than the modern algorithms
and then the particular instantiation
of a revolution that is brewing in
uh weird countries right now but it is
it is circling around the same the same
goal of basically
relieving individuals of their human
agency
yes and there's a um
there is a deep flaw in
the psyche that does not recognize that
effectively
consuming is a debt that you owe
to the world and to the extent that you
are going to consume and consume
then it's all debt now the question is
can you bring something of value to the
world that begins to
address the you know the fact of your
having consumed all that stuff that's
the hope and
you know i i'm not intending to blame
anybody who doesn't have the tools to be
productive but the fact is we should be
thinking in these terms what is the
point
of a life in which you know the most
um productive thing you did was
you know basically curate a series of
brands into some kind of
you know slightly personal identity
right that's not
that's nothing to aspire to and um
so anyway yes uh i
am increasingly disturbed by the fact
that it seems to me that we have a very
immediate problem the solution to which
is obviously
uh several generations
of work right what do we do about the
fact that
um if you solved the problem of
woke ideology in our slide towards
totalitarianism
tomorrow you still have a large
population of people who have been
hobbled by the stupid way we have
dealt with um education and
uh development and pharmaceuticals
and all of that stuff and you know
there's no way around it that has to be
dealt with and it is actually our
collective obligation to deal with it
yes um and if we don't it will come for
us
and it and it seems to be doing so so
maybe that's
uh maybe maybe that's the place to
and for right now we went close to two
hours i think
um all right so we will
however be back uh in i guess not the
second hour but call it something like
the third hour
to answer some of your questions that
were asked in super chat this hour and
next hour
you can find a bit more from us at
either of our websites or on our
patreons where you could join the
discord server
and be part of a conversation of some
such like-minded people
and as was in the quote that i was just
reading
[Music]
if you want access to a private q a once
a month
join my patreon if you're interested in
uh
extended conversations in small groups
at uh at a higher
money level joining brett's and
we'll be back in 15 minutes all right
see you in 15.
[Music]